hello ladies and gentlemen I'm Eric
that's Rob hi what's up what are we
playing today Rob my favorite game of
last year titanfall 2 and why are we
playing it because there's another
update oh yeah is it a hot update it's a
pretty hot update ok
hotter yeah I mean it's no new Titan but
two new maps a third slot for another
pistol and anti-titan weapon some other
changes new game-mode but yeah I'm into
it I'm gonna be into it yeah you are I
mean I the the little thing I want to
preface to was that in the morning when
we knew about kind of the having the
additional weapons slot you guys are
really hoping that it was gonna be a
primary and it turns out it's just a
pistol right or whistle or anti-titan
weapon yeah and like and that's the
thing is like you know that's almost too
good to be true like that's a pretty big
game-changer is it though I think but
this is fine this is this is like
wouldn't you really think about it this
should have always been in the game in
the game like you should just have a
pistol ready like and not have to it's
like whenever you switch modes like for
instance this is Titan for all mm-hmm
well not this mode but like last Titan
standing like you're not gonna have a
pistol like you want anti-titan weapon
if you ever get you know ejected and
vice versa if you're pilots only you not
gonna have any anti-titan weapon you
want a pistol so I think I feel like it
makes things easier in our bed what's up
a little legit in the YouTube chat I
will be monitoring twitch and YouTube
chat as well as a GameSpot you know hit
us up with your questions we'll try to
do the best to answer mainly Rob's gonna
be answering I'm just gonna shuttle the
questions off to him and do some
commentary
what's up goob and yeah there's a third
weapon slot Homer oh man hopefully I
didn't put your name I and there's a new
execution right that you're like one
away yeah I'm one away from so I just
gotta kill one more pilot when I haven't
engaged hello how are you and yeah so
check that out so to get it you have to
pretty much have your hollow pilot or
whatnot active and then you just have to
kill an enemy pilot and it counts
towards your total to unlock the
execution right believe it's 20 was it
20 kills 20 kills yeah so we're one away
and hopefully Rob can show you that
kneel shadowboxing I saw execution I saw
it this morning it's pretty cool it's
like he sends each one of his pilots to
like beat someone and he just stands
there it's it's kind of neat Buckeye boy
the DLC is out on ps4 already um not do
you know if it's out on Xbox it I don't
I just know it's pouring out on a ps4
that's what we're playing on right now
yeah what's up Tyrone a full of fully
well I hope you're doing well thanks for
tuning in thanks to everyone for tuning
in yeah
if you haven't already subscribed to our
YouTube channel we stream or are going
to stream every day at 11:00 a.m.
sometimes a little bit more depending on
what's out and what updates and DLCs are
out but you know make sure to subscribe
and hit that follow button on Twitch so
you guys know when we go live with new
gameplay all that fun stuff hopefully we
get maybe some good gameplay here oh oh
you'll be fine
I have faith in you oh yeah and I'm also
in the North Star which is dumb to be
alone also just so you guys know I will
be doing the Diablo 3 Necco stream later
sometime after titanfall when it
releases also Rob's gonna be back on
Friday oh I believe yeah breath of the
wild DLC comes out him and Peter will be
checking out all that fun stuff
damn oh that wasn't no he was that was
his hallo
dammit well-played he got me yeah Peter
and are streaming that for a while we're
gonna try to do like four hours maybe
nice-nice that yeah trials with a sword
at least two plus right yeah I can't see
you I should not be focusing on you at
all and what nine nine one asking what
actually happened in this update he just
started watching so um to my
understanding this is the new map war
games then you have a live-fire map you
have a new mode called I wrote down free
agents I'm not yep if you can describe
that very remember what exactly that
mode is so lucky for me I have it pulled
up so free agents the new mode is a
free-for-all with a twist
you collect three batteries to call in
the Titan battery locations are placed
around the map that's right pilots drop
a batteries on death right so the only
way you get your Titan is if you have
three batteries of time so you're racing
around it's almost like um I guess I
would kind of want to say kill confirms
as far as like how you treat deaths okay
where you know you don't just
necessarily kill a guy you it you got to
go to his dead corpse and pick up a
battery so that seems pretty neat
hopefully we'll run into this this is
just the playlist called wargames 24/7
yeah this is a new networking yeah and
then there's yeah two new maps one for
live-fire this new weapon slot which I
have currently I was telling you is kind
of like destiny and the respective like
to like engage your what does that
weapon is just like your what's your
like your heavy weapon is that what it
is yeah that's a heavy you do you praise
yeah yes so you can nail it on the head
there right you just hold triangle or
why and that's how you can pull out your
like third slot now so I think it's just
natural you mean you can customize it
however you want but I think it's
natural to think of it as like alright
that's me my anti Titan and then I'll
have my pistol at the ready Harry Murphy
we are currently on ps4 that's the
console that Rob's been playing it on we
haven't checked to see if it's out on
Xbox one yet I think Aaron didn't see it
on PC yes yeah earlier generally it's
been it's late afternoon for some reason
I feel like they just like hit it pretty
early on ps4 yeah so we just know for a
fact that it the the patch is out on ps4
maybe someone in check and also
confirmed
Marvins our saying it's not on xbox or
pc hopefully there's a couple other
people that can chime in to kind of
verify that or maybe I can look it up on
the reddit oh but the other thing is
like well they didn't really list in
their patch notes there's a lot of kind
of interesting changes is first
balancing like amped weapons is one of
your boosts that basically just beefs up
your all your weapons
they added a timer on to it now which is
pretty big like they really like nerfed
it so it's like 30 seconds so you have a
timer so it's like two miners like I
believe whenever you engaged amped
weapons maybe check and confirm I think
uses until you die or for a pretty long
time but now it's like substantially oh
come here
yeah you know what I want no I don't
want to be punched or executed Oh which
one is that guy on the Left running into
the wall no man that's a tactic or that
one no well the game before this we were
like talking about that one guy that was
just crouched the whole time we're like
wait yeah there's no way that's a real
guy right right and you kill them well
that's what's good interesting cuz yeah
in order to get the new execution right
you have to uh oh you're so done
Nick Ballard in YouTube chat saying he's
installing the update on Xbox one now so
that's cool I like this alley this is
kind of like just like a
like you can just get rocked like my
pilots in there Ricardo a we are showing
off some of the new stuff this is a new
map you know like the Mozart kind of
just like they they kind of shuffle
through right so yeah like you picked
pilot first all right
no no and this new mode I don't think I
can access didn't look like like
manually I have to like run into it I
guess with this playlist no but I was
saying earlier that guy was crouching
and like there's just so many people
using hallo pilots like he probably took
advantage of that which is like maybe
they won't maybe they won't notice cuz
there's so many different holograms
bunch of people saying they're updating
on Xbox site awesome thank you guys that
Rio Rio Kirito asking is there any more
single-player mode DLC coming out for a
tight ball - I don't know of any but I
don't know if you've heard anything
different I I don't think I've heard of
anything like that I don't think so
I doubt it really yeah I think the focus
is multiplayer and it should be I'd
rather have more multiplayer than
anything else
I mean campaign being yeah your
single-player experience that you had
was already like a pretty solid one one
that a lot of people enjoyed a couple
really memorable Maps well yeah and
what's funny is one of the things they
added was an Easter egg in that glitch
the teleporting map and single-player
they added an Easter egg which is kind
of neat I don't know I don't know if
that's gonna bring me back to it but
yeah maybe I'll look for it so now it's
just them polishing their multiplayer
right yeah it tons of balances another
really cool one I think is the the evac
ship oh right when yeah it I noticed it
happen we're like if when everyone on
the team is dead or if everyone is on
the evac ship it doesn't hang around
anymore it takes off which is kind of
Awesome and a way in a way where it's
like alright yeah let's let's wrap this
map up for this matchup and move on
hello oh no fear oh no fear Rob Cody's
suitors asking what's the deal with
phase shift is it only one use now Oh
what I don't know if you have this
there's only one we can look at it in a
second there you get this execution
there I got it you have it yes no I got
that execution yeah wheat yeah it's kind
of weird switching to the anti thing
hold it oh yeah because you put your
pistol on you're a secondary oh yeah
you're done come on come on give me the
lock you're crazy
you're a wild man Richard Aguila this is
one of the new maps yeah this is the new
map wargames you could say it's the
front center update highlight if you
will so there must have been some type
of phase shift nerf because Nick
Ballard's you compare Heineken Fermi in
a way he's saying hopefully the the
phase shift nerf will encourage other
players to use other abilities instead
of being a phase shift attic well find
out saying we will find out and you can
equip the execution right damn they're
pieces pretty I love inter pieces but
the thing that'd last one two is random
which I like oh just do like it picks
one whatever right and they they also
added that so you can customize if you
have a prime Titan you can customize if
you want to use the prime or the
original execution because those are all
different so let's take a look at this
and make sure I'm not oh yeah another
thing they added was this is tight and
brawl so its last time standing except
that it's more team deathmatch you just
get right back in it which is nice
people really like that mode and it
wasn't originally gonna stay but now it
is permanently nice yes I'm not seeing
yeah it's only in here I guess or maybe
this sometimes the modes will roll out
later I
I didn't really see it in that playlist
but what's up Bob see shadowboxing your
spaceship will uh see if a ship see
what's about I like phase shift I'm not
very good at it very much a Juke move
mm-hmm ha Jukes Marvins our there is a
new execution shadow by he just unlocked
it so we'll see how many of those he can
get yeah the new update did take a while
yeah I was like two gigs okay yeah half
oh yeah I got four flex maybe CTU is
this a new map where's this one of the
this is this is the same map people just
play it okay yeah it just looks
different as a pilot here action
it's like like this is cool looking like
this
little Hollow tank little hollow tank
war games
wall game sounds like a mobile game oh
and this is gonna be a mute yeah you
didn't like that I don't like that right
I also don't like that's what you do I
think that's what I do when you're not
on stream yeah at home that's exactly
right
okay let's try it out on this guy it was
afk quickly this is a cheap way to do it
but let's see it that's not it
no that was right that was last time oh
I must have screwed it up goddammit
great job Wow
let me read big guys wow this amateur
can't even do it on any of the day pick
Buckeye boy saying I wish that the
gaming community embraced this game more
because it's such a good game I think
that's like most I it's it's an
interesting thing because like you and
Aaron both really enjoy this game
there's a couple other people with Mike
as well and it's one of those things
like when you're playing it you know you
totally like it and you're enjoying it
but there's like I don't know I guess
there's so many different FPS games that
[ __ ] you know I'm a destiny guy so like
I just enjoy destiny yeah but like I
mean I understand the like just a smooth
movement of this game
can't even see it we couldn't even see
it
because it was the camera angle oh [ __ ]
no you're not real God did you shoot
each other did he probably just ran away
beautiful yeah oh that's way cooler than
I thought they just hit his head
exploded that's pretty good that was
pretty [ __ ] six my language oh wow I
ran the but damn that was awesome I
wonder the Kody suitor about two and a
half gigs roughly what's up go back
what's up neurosis oh I loved it I just
thought he liked warped into him kind of
like their pieces like intervener pieces
yeah I don't know so like so far from
the ones that have come out which one is
kind of like your like favorite favorite
yeah inner peace is for sure just
because you're like you warp into their
body and explode up oh excuse me just
like that burp but when I didn't like as
much was the last one I think it was the
pulse blade one
where you like postulate is a thing it's
a sonar blade you or excuse me sonar
played yeah no pools played anyway so
you just like jump on their shoulders
and then just stab them in the head it's
cool but it's not as cool as the other
one yeah that that other one they like
the like insane speed punched into the
ground that was called oh that I like
hundred the one I messed up last hit I
think yeah yeah it's like it man have
you ever won yes man that's exactly it
we've done a facebook video of it if you
want to see what it looks like but yeah
dang it oh hi yeah outplayed not really
hi how are you
dang it so yeah at least you got that
first guy I didn't even think you're
gonna get him Marvin's hour I did
pre-order destiny - I'm looking forward
to it will be playing the beta in a
month I'm excited for that
yeah that's gonna be my time to come
it's like I think it's a good time for
anyone that missed out also gonna be
opening it up to PC players which is
like a huge demographic feels great on
mouse keyboard - me and John we've got
to play it at the destiny events and
then some other of our co-workers were
able to play it in at e3 so I must
protect this guy yes s :
o epic epic sis excuse me I feel like
cysts are already pretty epic oh yeah
yeah but you know I Jedi huh
you're part of the dark you're alright
you're definitely safe good let the hit
you are you
when is it Oh what's that guy yeah was
the one in the back yeah yeah yeah so
you used to be able to do that more than
once
no I can do it twice okay I'm looking at
right now I don't know maybe that maybe
they like nerf too fine with it or some
oh [ __ ] I'm curious yeah cuz that's the
thing is they're actually they're pretty
good about adding all their changes but
I do appreciate them sometimes they'll
emit the they'll be like you know we're
not gonna like we're not gonna reveal
what we balanced because then you'll
notice it like we want to like you know
it's it's like a case study right like
you gotta like house a case study oh hi
Rex granted that's a human boy but that
yeah Bob if we're allowed to we will
stream the data for sure I do the same
okay will there be wizards on the moon
and destiny to say darude sandstrom
do-do-do-do-do
there I said it
you noticed my black skin on this time i
means i gen 210 okay yeah it's sick [ __ ]
i seriously that was like my that was
the biggest wedgie
like oh cool you got a black skin did
you buy that was a cosmetic okay
cuz you can do that right yeah they have
a camel backs different I bought one of
them because I just love this game
because you're like rocking that Mike
Wazowski almost oh hell yes being right
hell yeah
neurosis asking am I going to pax no I'm
not you know who is going to pack that's
a good question I think so yeah oh my
got my my super oh no that's a court
this is the worst part about that damn
Microsoft rains but no we're flight
we're Sox man
oh no you're not real Faye's it again
then it's good call all you don't need
to oh we saw you to the honey but he
also alright yeah that's smart
snipers will do that God that's smart I
love it which one is it
Joshy boy say North Stars BAE I love you
love North Star oh do it do you'll see
well it's not he'll see patches free
right right oh yeah I'm really all that
so no sure it is free go update it
apparently
definitely out on ps4 and a lot of the
chat is has been saying that it's out on
Xbox one so definitely go on slow down
slow down
no leave him alone
don't touch us he's ours no we're wife
phase did he face it or there's no way
that was a hollow right cuz that was
pretty good bout that was weird
see the other guys hopefully at all yeah
I think that was favored look I was
telling you I feel like the phase shift
is like different he's got to swing
would he go yeah I forgot much I like
phase shift it's just like a second
chance
right
Marvin's Howard here's your shout out
shout out to you I'm so hot there is
still a lot of people that play this
game I think that if you are already
playing it you're gonna continue playing
it and they keep giving good free
updates so why wouldn't you play it now
if you weren't into the multiplayer that
much I could see why you've might've
stopped playing but it's harder yeah if
you don't like the multiplayer it's hard
to recommend this game to be honest I
think the multi single-player ISM is
really awesome I just I mean they get
sheep now so I take it back I guess it's
like 20 I like it yeah someone like a
half your age
I even think like yeah thirty baby whoa
excuse me I was laughing Mike Heller oh
now you're a pea coop it was a pig Bob
kept saying I'm surprised Eric's not
screaming the necro I will be it's not
out on PC yet I don't believe but it
might have come out because they were
just doing maintenance so I wouldn't be
shocked if they did release it I'll be
doing that later don't you fret
we do have the new execution we get it
earlier we'll try again in a hot second
no no you will die where are you oh yeah
Jacob Kimball saying I don't have the
update on icebox yet maybe try turning
off your Xbox one and turning it back on
I know that's a way around or like a way
to help solve that issue sometimes cuz I
know that happens during overwatch
updates as well yeah it can be a little
finicky like that yeah just know that
the patch is pretty big about two and a
half gigs so it's gonna take you a
little bit if you don't have yeah I mean
Internet and if you're doing a piece for
put that put that on standby
what's up Benjamin rub rub rub little
rub that off hopefully set that right oh
okay
look at her now I'm all black look at
this how threatening is this god-emperor
virus a I like how they made the small
touch of both in tf1 and tf2 for enemy
pilots and AI and war games to have the
hollow pile of echt further making the
fact that you're in a simulator true
there's also yep that is true brach one
there is a glitch or there's an easter
egg on that glitch right mm-hmm
the shadow plays thanks for tuning in um
he said his update just finished so see
you later make sense or you're just
leave it on while you're playing but
that's right hard yeah yeah yeah I would
be kind of hard to point two six four
gigs says Benjamin rubble ello Rob Leto
I round it up yeah that's fine we said 2
to 2.5 Rob lead Oh Rob lead Oh
thank you for helping me correctly say
your name
Oh John Fox Wayne
this is a cool system should be in more
games basically GSP and spud yeah we
have to
oh there's two giant bombs then I yeah
again IGN it's true - yeah
Oh piles were spots we can try after
this how much time we got we got time we
got some time and I I said that I
probably wouldn't stop detailed 12:30
unless dope gets tiring dope I can do
that oh whoa
oh this will he's talking about huh hey
I didn't understand what you're saying
that's this is cool
ready we're gonna be it you ready Adam
lera asking uh what's your favorite gun
Rob um my favorite gun is the IVA
shotgun for sure and if you look at my
stats I think it's like $3.00 pills like
I feel a little under three but I'll
give you three I'll let you round up
again but right now yeah that was really
cool a real good shooting there but they
they kinda nerfed it it's got like it's
got less range and boom so I'm like not
as inclined to use anymore but I think
second would be the alternator which is
what I got right here
Benjamin Rob Leto thank you for the kind
words really appreciate it got him ooh
okay here we go you ready ready ready
two guys with the same Oh for you
boom boom there's another guy with the
same last name Aaron now he's saying to
pronounce which I thought was Rob Lee do
you say Robledo Robledo or oblate oh oh
no those I don't know which one it is
but oh I thought you're going for it and
I almost really get greedy I know for
the back-to-back execution
back-to-back-to-back alright let's try
on this
big dump daughter over here where is he
I like this map though eighty-six
buzz-saw saying he just tuned in and
sorry for the potentially stupid
question but isn't this a map from
titanfall one it is so not a stupid
question and I verified a lot a lot of
them it's like a little a lot of the
maps I'm totally cool they're like it's
not just like like sure that you know
reuse assets we're gonna say but there
are awesome maps and they definitely
touch them up nicely like I think this
looks pretty great here's an interesting
one for you Rob velcro well not so much
a question but just a statement but
velcro snake and twitch testing turns
out some of the changes in the patches
were unintentional as purge a fresh
underscore respawn on reddit they'll be
getting rolled back Oh what like what
maybe like the amped weapons ones Oh No
that's interesting that could make sense
you know it's like that happens I don't
know because I don't know how you would
change a modifier or chant like modify
something and not know so hard to say
philanthropy saying our been junk out
out in our pit necromancer is pretty
cool guys
ding so is it live been they went early
or earlier than expected which is not
that come down here my friend everyone
gaming our Ryan Schubert Oh God saying
this is one of the best maps in title
I wasn't directly behind on that's not
an executed uh-oh
now I understand what number was saying
oh I'm still like the phase shift looks
different people work because sometimes
when he kills someone and they have
phase shift and they try to do it before
you kill him it'll like show remnants of
it but they'll actually die but in this
map everyone is is a hologram so that's
what you're seeing I just did not put
that together we've posted making big
plays man I know that's what I'm talking
and playing it stuff mm-hmm
velcro snake I don't think you're gonna
be able to link it because I think mu
BOTS gonna eat your link so we
appreciate it thank you for the update
on that one if you find out anything
specific in terms of what it changes
give me a shout I guess I'll also just
pull it up maybe maybe I can just look
at the war game or the awarding the
titanfall ready
hey yeah got him got him ninja stad I
love a fire starts so good
Rob's actually Naruto he doesn't know
who that is though there is an amped nur
Giovanni
not sure if that's one of the ones that
were like mistakingly hello sorry yeah
there wasn't a manner it's a timed right
you said like 30 seconds 30 seconds yeah
I don't know what it was before but
there I mean I don't know because there
wasn't a timer on it but now there is so
you're being really conservative with
those that could be one of if you're if
you're talking about additions to this
update yeah that were accidental that
could be one because it wasn't listed so
Benjamin's saying yeah so not just amped
weapons with stem and pages oh I got
nerfed I guess
also Caleb's saying great job playing
what is your favorite pilot club for
sure I acted like a hologram
what are you doing he's running straight
sure oh oh oh oh oh dang it
I came from down that man I know when I
was down here it looked like he was
typing it looked like he was sniffing
that's fair okay but when I when I got
to him when I got to my new I just
wanted to punch cyborg man no new Titans
this time around now but there are gonna
be two more and that's yeah I think you
can expect those probably both releasing
and in periodic updates but I think
that's gonna happen
Dillon H just confirming that amped
weapons it used to be you know your
whole life
oh it was yeah that's that's actually
kind of insane to think about it that's
I don't know I never I never really used
amped weapons I mean it's the first
boost you get but it's a mean it's a
solid oh geez you're my buddy
Saldana know I lately I've been using
the extra battery for Northstars really
great because I use them a lot of
Northstar damn it
insidious vision we are on YouTube and
twitch as well as GameSpot so we're in
multiple locations again I'll be mainly
monitoring chat chatting with you guys
fielding your questions for Rob so you
have questions for Rob feel free to kind
of you know go ahead and ask them and I
will relay them to him while he gets a
sick execution maybe I'll explode inside
Oh at least you got one man Adam Lehrer
I would assume that Rob got decently
good now he says how are you so good at
the game
why oh I'm not good at all I've slept
good thank you it just comes from the
sky playing a lot a lot it's generally
how you get pretty good I like my
favorite part about this game is the
system movement is so fun it's like and
see I'm not very good at shooting oh oh
oh he threw a gravity star that's that
was sick that was a cool move on his
part
yeah your round shucks that's such a
awesome combo for like something like
that I just did that was really cool
I've never seen that some of the stuff
that like I love yeah like hooked on
these but on this game in particular is
those kind of moments you and Ryan
sharing those kind of stories like oh
dude this totally happened last night
right discounters this and that
countered that and I think you guys even
talked about it early on when this game
came out that it's and I think even the
devs from respawn we're saying like it's
kind of like they want to have that more
fighting game read kind of gameplay
where there's counters and stuff like
counters exactly and that's that's very
much the the Titans right that's the
move they made with those guys with like
the predictability like all right a
North Star I know exactly like that
should if I this is the Eva man I should
have in two hits potato man we can't get
in the Titan right now cuz this pilot
where's pilot mode Dylan H the
prerequisite for getting the execution
is you just have to have the like hollow
thing the hollow pilot skill and as long
as that's active and you kill another
enemy pilot then that starts to accrue
for the unlock and you need 20 of those
yeah take you that long bow Rob oh oh
Oh oh that's too hard to get that was
out if I did that would have been
freaking awesome
I'm out now that's yeah we talked about
it earlier the other neat feature they
added was like the evac ship when
everyone is inside it leaves which is
cool cuz like one you're you're speeding
up the match it's just pointless to live
wait around but also if the team has
like all their Titans and they're just
shooting that dropship it will almost
always get wrecked so like you a lot of
times you just weren't like sitting
there like right like you weren't
leaving in time so it's nice to like
kind of again reward the evac feature or
just mechanic in general someone saying
let us see the ronan prime execution
sound fix that was the mix-up life of
NHS I just explained how they get the
execution you can DVR back if you need
to just use the hollow PI of 20 kills do
you like monarch Rob I really like
monarch but it's it's a very hard Titan
to use I would want to keep using it I
still want to I mean I could try it out
right now it's just so much going on
with that Titan yeah we've talked about
it before it's just like it's it takes a
lot of skill because the whole point of
the mark obviously is to get to that
third core upgrade and then you're
rockin yeah but prior to that you're
you're very weak and you can get taken
down pretty quickly
Liz James a familiar name in the YouTube
chat saying and we're asking if you had
an office titanfall 2 tournament at
GameSpot who would win
I that's a tough one for me there's only
there's only like there's only three
wars there's like four it's you Ryan and
and Mike Ryan Ryan is pretty good I
think I think I know he's a hired Gen
than me
sounds like you guys should play for
lunch or something why honey is on Rob
mainly because he's in here and if I
didn't say that I think I'd be in
trouble
smart man Oh what Jen are you someone
else uh top right there says seven seven
point three four seven ish big Buckeye
boy saying I love tone do you like tone
I don't I've used so much Northstar and
likes court I'd really like scorches
like probably my second favorite that I
like socket okay yeah well dark ghost X
or X X are you ready X X I'm not ready
bro three weapons slots are back hell
yeah just just so you know it's still
one primary and then you know pistol or
anti tighten and then pistol and then
anti-titan right yeah I haven't really
been using it that mop that often you're
using it when we were warming up yeah
you're I mean it's still nice right like
yeah like you can still like the problem
shock on officer Reyes is your long
range is [ __ ] so a wingman elite is a
good solution to that
Andrew Saenz is asking is the new map a
nice and fluid any tips or tricks for us
yeah I think so oh I don't
tips and tricks for this map I don't
know play a lot yeah sorry Ryan that's
right I said Rob Andres sashka asking
there are going to be other Titans you
said too right yeah there's two more
and I think they're a rumor to be like
because they had concept art that like
showed this like guy can remember the
name
not ox I'll go looking for it it's fine
it's like that like a anyways it's just
it's a heavy class heavy chassis like he
had explosive it was a grapple that's
right it was like a grapple tighten that
like could bring you you could like
bring it tighten to it oh here we go
okay Oh side work man roughly
two-point-three cakes is what I'm going
with now not even going to bother with
that one insidious that other game
you're talking about isn't even out just
trying to catch up on chat glad you guys
are all tuning in me and Rob appreciated
thanks for chatting with us hanging out
with us remember to hit that subscribe
button follow button on Twitch and uh
yeah thanks guys thank you guys and just
to give you guys some more updates on
what's going on the rest of the week
I'll be doing a necro d3 livestream
ruffed of roughly you know after this
maybe 30 minutes after this and then
tomorrow we of course have the lobby
John Luke and Jake are gonna play with
some law breakers beta tomorrow hmm
keep it coming yeah wait is that
tomorrow that's tomorrow I think and
then I think Joe and John Luke are doing
some stuff on Thursday yes we'll get to
your Friday stream Friday Rob and Peter
no be doing oh no that's what you get
for thinking about Legend of Zelda and
not keeping your head in the game you're
absolutely right yeah yeah Adam Lyra
asking how long have you played this
game like roughly oh look we can look at
the stats later how long have I been
playing this game I've been playing this
game pretty much since I was like we'll
run release like I'll have like wins
mm-hmm so to speak well like all right
I'm back and that's generally around
updates right all right back in it and
I'll play for like a weekend or like a
whole week then maybe I'll take a break
because of course we like to play other
games here yeah it should
gucchi tried saying what about diagonals
rob thicke Bob said he he made a load
trade this week normally John Luke and
Joey have the Friday 11:00 a.m. time
slot again we do stream every day Monday
to Friday at 11:00 a.m. but they did a
little swap so that they could play some
Legend of Zelda or breath of the wild
Friday DLC yeah so yeah probably dinos
next week yeah yeah Joey says he was a
wee lad just hopped on when does this
update drop it is out Justin marks er on
ps4 and xboxone parent yeah go ahead and
find that update 2.3 ish gigs yeah free
update this bozo here buddy
devil gaming asking what's your idea or
what would be your idea to get more
players into this game good question I
don't know maybe like I think they had a
wave base mode III drifted off the first
game but I'm pretty sure there was a
wave base mode oh yeah they added that
like way later right yeah big updates if
not like the last update so I never
actually got to that but I think that
could be cool
oh yeah I'm [ __ ] marnark do it nailed
it
oh man it's been a while that guy time
two in a row so the whole thing with
Mark is you literally like have to like
this hang back
oh no like engaging this guy probably
dumb Marmont are we are definitely not
trash-talking breath of the wild
everyone in the office loves it so my
still playing to that that's the other
game I'm still playing I would just say
if you're playing breath of the wild and
you're even remotely close to killing
Ganon or thinking about killing game Joe
just say don't do it no don't do it why
I stopped playing once I killed Ganon
like ice oh yeah I'm not very good I'm
recording that one by the way just so
you know we can use that later guys I
just think that once you began in
there's just no point to playing the
game anymore
I don't know nah dude side though the
side quests are so good there Ganon is
literally the least interesting part no
that's what I'm saying okay like I'm
just saying that I feel like because I
beat Ganon oh you're done like I just
like felt like I'm sure done with the
game even though yes you're right
there's plenty of side quests a lot of
things to explore that's a good point
like if I didn't kill him I would have
just kept playing I would eat more
shrines I would have looked around like
oh the world more like upgraded my armor
more you know all these things I agree
and instead I was like ah you know maybe
I'll go do Ganon round and then I was
like super Opie oh my god Wow
ya know I I really agree with you on
that let's change this up Oh II PGA I've
been using this lot
oh but wait let's make sure we got the
new execution no that's not it oh it is
that's good my then I keep thinking
shadow boxing's it man but it's not this
lets go with ya
cyborg man we will be checking out the
breath of the wild dlc if that's what
you're asking about oh yeah yeah only
are robbing Peter planning to do
potentially for hours if not more yeah
well try to do that two to four hour
range I guess half a day yeah well do
the the trials and we'll see how far we
can get so we starting a campaign to get
Tay back into zeldo man yeah I'm done we
have enough people playing Zelda yeah
I'm I just I just dude you okay
you know you're gonna come back and try
to get that armor the phantom armor oh
you know you know you want that that the
one that looks like a bull yes maybe
dude maybe just for the armor yeah I
don't know that's what I'm doing right
now I'm just leveling up armor like a
loser yeah I was I was doing that too
right so before I went to fight Canyon I
was like okay let me get all the armor
and then let me make sure I upgrade the
ones I really like right but then that
started getting a little bit tedious and
then I was just like all right let me
just upgrade the armors I really like so
I got barbarian - I want to say mostly
max or close to max mm-hmm
I was like I'm just gonna go do this
right and then you beat him in five
seconds I wouldn't say five seconds but
he wasn't I didn't I don't even feel
like I you really used the master sword
to its full capability I don't even feel
like you needed I needed the Master
Sword
to be honest dude yeah I was just the
whole time yeah like I was stalling yeah
I was like all right I I don't want it
to end so quickly so I'm like just like
teasing him I felt like but whatever
like I'm excited for that hero mode
Benjamin asking how did you guys unlock
the execution so fast I don't know I I
would say it's a combination of luck and
skill but it's not too hard because
remember it's just you you activate your
hollow pilot and you just have to kill
enemy pilots so that's not even
executing up
a pilot it's just normal you know just
kill them oh you want to know another
change I heard is that stalkers are the
bigger robots it was a little loud not
the biggest those Reapers other ones are
really tough to go but apparently if you
walk over them with a tinier her - like
a lot more cat and mouse right now let's
see I missed some stuff
can you run two pistols or two
anti-titan yes yeah you can do two
pistols that was for Cody a suitor was
James says he actually left shaking my
head and happened I did leave what are
your tips it's all right
Adam Lyra asked more your tips to stay
alive I'll start with probably just
saying learn the maps while running wall
running movement yeah yeah it's
something I wish I'm I was better I was
shooting oh I'm shooting while wall
running it's tough yeah I would just say
familiar like that's familiarizing
yourself with the maps is pretty canned
for sure oh yeah
a manufactured fracture I don't know if
you're still here but peace out he said
his downloads done so he's gonna have
that go get it
argh argh alack one what you Pilate kits
would you like to have robbed
a new pilot I don't know I never thought
of that
what's what's like an ability maybe like
a UH what like what's like a dead one
from destiny I don't know maybe like
some sort of like maybe like a shield
like a dome shield
I guess not like a dome one though huh
for your buddies they kind of have that
a wall that's that's more like a damaged
out output maybe like a dome like some
halo 3 you know that bubble shield
maybe something like that yeah it's the
same thing as this Oh her destiny cop
copy I'm gonna go with that because it
was Bungie it is Bungie um discourse got
a buff I didn't hear about that
I hope not oh it someone saying like a
Reinhard shield for a Titan definitely
not be self res dangerous they got rid
of it that's not even gonna be in
destiny - oh well no we're relating
destiny skills - what you could add four
pilots in titanfall - really what's the
what's the hand cannon ability of the
Hunter has Golden Gun Golden Gun don't
you kind of its kind of amped weapons
but yeah you could transfer that into
like an ability if you're just like one
shot one kill
kind of thing yeah that could be cool Oh
what's up let's see if we can see this
live fire map hopefully eh it'll show up
do wait I'm trying to find that concept
art you're talking about hardpoint I'm
leaving you would get penalized I'll
take it like what's like that it's like
a name for like an ox or like a Bisons
this guy right suffice it says it's
bison on there yeah that dude all right
um are you gonna I'm gonna I'm gonna get
something for you guys - who this
copilot action I couldn't work at this
to work but hold on we're getting that
concept art or I'm gonna try to and then
you guys so he the rumor is that he has
like a grat like the grapple so we can
pull Titans towards him hollow like
scorpion
get over here exactly and he also
you have free agents in the chat I don't
I mean I think it's either they haven't
added it yet because they do that
sometimes with modes or it's in that
playlist but we're just not so this is
this this is a guy you're talking about
right yeah so this is constant this was
in the art book I think is what I just
read um and so there's there's the
speculation is that maybe this is one of
the unreleased Titans and then there's
this guy - do you want you want me to
get this guy - oh yeah I think that's
him still but that was that yeah that's
that's him again
I think but it makes sense because if
you're gonna add three new Titans so
they've added one already its monarch
which has a medium build chassis you'd
have a heavy and you'd have a light like
a North Star or Ronin and what that
light one I don't know of any rumors
what it would be like if you we got
light you have like long and short range
already Ronin and in a sniper class so I
guess would be like a medium as far as
range but they're pretty sick he's got
that grammar so where's the grapple
though it's highs right on he's like
doing like an Ironman thing I think in
the description to it like mentions that
it was like an idea of theirs I'm into
it yeah I don't even know if we're gonna
look out in this new life fire map I'm
gonna find out the meadow
this isn't it the Bison prime win no
idea bison pride they haven't even
really spiced and yet when I don't know
I mean I'd say in a couple months maybe
like I think I feel like both would be
released by the end of the year I want
to say someone in chat was like saying
there's gonna be maybe a big update in
July oh really this is kind of laggy
oh I didn't get your 50 G's that is a
sick-ass name
unfortunately no fortnight's are galacon
otherday this is some real butts butts
butts ping yeah oh no your pings
fluctuating oh look at that ping good
high bass something with a live fire
game I don't know it could just Oh
did you try the free agents thing I
don't so I don't know how to get to it
uh I I think they're holding back on it
okay like they did it last time with
their other modes like oh I got it I got
it
alright swifty cheese there's something
swifty about him I think he's bringing
all this live with them I cannot shoot
[ __ ] there's no paid DLC with this
update I'm out I'm not doing this I
wouldn't either
it's a horrible experience for everyone
myself included I'll bring back the
Bison picture oh shoot yeah bison looks
like scorch it looks like scorch prime
there you guys go
here's course Prime oh you got scorched
prime yeah it looks a lot like on the
left on the left yeah dude looks a lot
doesn't have the Schult the big ol
shoulders though you got more like a
backpack thing going on this course is
so sick why'd you play scourge then okay
that was not that hard to convince right
there you know how to convince me yeah
well
hmm well yeah new Titans let's hope well
you said there's gonna be two right two
more yeah I'm expecting firm to confirm
I'm yeah I'm like 99% sure they said
three Newtons I'm hoping for a tie
telling if they're gonna do that like
kind of like you know grapple Titan I'm
hoping for like another elemental Titan
like a because they're had they had the
arc gun and the Protoss game that was
like you know like electric gun so I'm
thinking like a EMP core or something
like that were you just like Fri
everyone's circuits oh man
that could be neat could be and yeah
it's just one but or like not bug but
like I'm trying to mute people in this
loading through your greeting is gone
dude why and if you're on the bad
internet I could unplug you and plug you
into some mill if it's laggy you all do
that potentially will see 800 that's not
good
no I mean it was fine earlier I don't
know maybe we're getting beat off just
kidding that would never happen people
trying to bring down my game if it's bad
Rob what I do is this is bad wood okay
then I would unplug the internet that
you have now and take the internet from
that PC to your left and try that
got it right
all right we're doing it we'll just go
to the camera real quick while he does
that and I'll stop recording that that
was junk but yeah thanks for tuning in
thanks for your patience apparently we
had some nice high ping there will be
mom we're trying to solve that right now
but um we are playing titanfall 2 the
new update 3 weapon slots now but only
two of the three are you know either a
hand a hand cannon hand gun hand cannon
and a anti-titan weapon so you can
choose between the two or you can have
two of the same and then you still have
your primary obviously and then there's
two new maps it's a new mode called free
agent mode that we're not sure haven't
seen yet I mean look how to get into so
I don't think you saw it at the bottom
there though right
it would so it would specify here yeah
so maybe they're holding that one back I
think they're holding it they're gonna
roll it out later
and then there's new execution alright
we'll show it off again yeah we're gonna
get that shadowboxing but yeah please
don't be pilots first pilots I want to I
want to push it up of course so fun
scorch has the best core where you just
like do this like hammer throw and just
wave a fire so it's fun to like
basically I have now scorched earth so
that wall of fire everything in between
me and it is like you can take heavy
damage I can just coat the ground the
fire and I also have over core engaged
so I get 20% of my ticker core ticker on
so I can get to it quicker anyways it's
just cool that's about it you seem
interested house force pilots sick your
favorite sorry I was looking up
something for what if bison had a
shoulder charge I like that like Titan
from
my god
gonna meet that guy for me yeah thank
you that sweet thanks trying to see if
that loggers beta tomorrow is just
closed or open well rocket Titan well
they kind of have rocket Titan with tone
already it's basically all Rockets
scorch Prime has the best high-end
execution oh yeah it does
it's so sick so good so good is that
Mike's favorite scorch or didn't he kind
of switch Titans you have a nice not
very good
dang how's the lag now feels pretty good
good no excuses then nope that was an
excuse that was no yeah Mike like
scorched gorgeous is fun to use it's
like Bob Jones telling me that the
lawbreakers beta is open to everybody
Oh me likey from downtown it wasn't that
far but it felt far Midtown Midtown I
can be like one of those uh warrior
bench players that like everyone hit a
really far shot I'll just reload oh I'd
love that
come on I was ready to reload it Oh
close but no cigar pouring law what's
your quick question fire I don't know
what it is you got to tell us fire away
oh oh oh you just got the normal punchy
one that's boring yeah he's boring oh
yeah I remember you got to show off that
execution okay okay I saw a guy boom
yeah it's not mean to do that
oh and you just saw anyone else why are
you comparing everything with destiny um
well I just hear a suggestion and then
I'm like well that's in another game
that I play cuz I like this he likes
destiny he lets just go to it that's my
go-to it's a okay yeah you know we're
here to celebrate games oh yeah that was
like a nice little like backboard shot
hell yeah doing that geometry oh come on
got him get out of there real hot hot
Rob nope Adam
oh you're dominating Rob Liz James wants
you to do your tutor saw that now come
on she's I won't she comes back to the
chat at least once or twice a week no
I'm not gonna no I can't do that
fantastisch not a monkey dance monkey
dance so yaar monkey where'd you go okay
yeah um what's that God do you think it
looks like that in the non war game map
though you know that's a good question
it's something completely different like
if his body just lays there instead mr.
B Fox a sweet love this map in tf1
yep
oh hello dudes ooh that was nice very
nice
Borat really very nice no ammo I was
gonna tell you thank you yeah I kind of
felt it kind of felt his presence I've
worked man saying do you guys feel that
the indoors looks like Mirror's Edge I
kind of like both play games
oh thank dang it's poser we done got
duped
Rob's hunting voice
like hope
oh-o-oh Martinez's who in your chair
what I don't know that's what he said I
forgot to wipe that's gross I would have
smelt it by now that's all natural all
oh here we go
No hey man you are making these kids
look like fools oh here we go guy it was
a fake it's guy right there oh very nice
very nice oh sorry
if the Borat skin well personally I dig
it I mean it it has an effect on me it's
working
Nance weapons I remember picking oh I
have dice roll this is dumb I should
have engaged it oh maybe not Oh what get
back here get your ass back here if
someone is asking about streaming you
can do it off the ps4 console itself or
as many others have mentioned you could
use like a Novato or a ver or anything
like that
but you could also use OBS OBS is
actually free and it's less intensive on
your PC are you trying to use PC yeah
I've heard good things about OBS
georgeharper to get the execution you
need to have a hollow pilot is it called
hollow pilot am I saying yes your hello
pilot the skill engaged and then kills
an enemy pilot wallets engaged it
doesn't matter how you kill them it
could be with your gun could be here
with your fists it doesn't matter tank
20 of those will then unlock it for you
it was pretty easy it was yeah the the
funniest was the first execution inner
peace is one illegals activity was 50
executions nope
oh he just got he was doing a jalapao
there he got I gave it to him I felt
that I gave it to him he needs me to get
a job they did a crew beforehand or was
it only what the DLC nice ICS replay
when the DLC hits you it yeah reset so
yeah you you wouldn't be able to auto
gun you wouldn't be able to auto get it
yeah yeah like started over okay
didn't take you that long though I think
you got like almost half of that in one
map so right oh come on the first time I
did it yeah I was working on all night
that was the thing
oh yeah leave him alone that's the
problem with executions so there's no I
mean I guess it wasn't what you could do
there cuz it's not like you're
invulnerable while it's happening
probably but like right after you like
you probably yeah right you don't have
enough time to react right like with
maybe you could have traded at best or
something yeah like and Titan Titans are
the same way when you do that
Oh what
the how they disappear like that is
really confusing you I feel like their
phase dashing I guess I'll get used to
it
if your tank earth if you're talking
about switching weapons between the
three it's it is hold versus tap tap
will get you in a secondary holding it
and then I have my own yep
my other one but then hold will get you
to your third one he's coming here
the reeds gadem he's map hacker that was
really dangerous - yeah kill me oh you
saw me what still another life yeah so
you know I don't sometimes there's like
a window of like five seconds mezu over
if you're if you're already in the game
I probably back out and then see if that
starts your update
Benjamin's what rate is right you can
actually get killed during x4 pilots you
can get killed during execution oh
really
yeah you totally Canada because I don't
have you still get the kill though or no
you like you can prevent like Halo has
that to or like you can stop someone
before they like Wow haptics so we could
be watching you potentially like the
have your hollow pilot jump kick but
that not and then like die before yeah I
guess yeah I'm pretty sure that it's
totally happened to me when I was trying
to get like an execution by performing
them get them nice but yeah with prime
so with you have a Titans you can't be
killed during execution oh I'm so sorry
I didn't record that one oh you didn't
record that but we have we have this
recording we have us talking over it
it's not the same though obviously they
don't they don't want to see my stupid
face nor mine I just have a better game
the last game okay now okay hopefully we
get some scorch action yeah hot scorch
I've so many calls same tickets what do
those do that is it's a game mode where
it's 1v1 and it's just like fight to the
death
three kills later Marvins art and you
get gifts like patches and banners
it's that's fun people people like it
this is really intense personally I'm
actually I'm just under strip scared of
it it's a scary mode fair enough oh my
god set my network to giant bomb get
those hot merits
maybe merits my next one on my next
stretch goal what's that this look at
that is that just for the teeth yeah
are you far from that one or you know
Garrett Jenna ma'am
victory victory what's a victory victory
at all yes bum that that free agents
mode isn't in this I'd like to I like to
play that oh I think it's there's like
pros and cons depending how you look at
it you get to you know be engaged with
what is out now and then like maybe in a
few days it's like oh free agent modes
yeah good point seeing with live fire to
I don't I don't really ever play that
mode though gotcha so will you be able
to scorch it up in this one I think you
trician damn right damn right god damn
right
let's to school so I love the Firestar
you oh wow that guy's angry but look man
he was in the last game oh man so that's
that's the other oh man
grapple that takes some skill I don't
like it but so you don't like skill got
it but how you like really utilize it
where'd this guy go
you cannot run your whatever you say I'm
actually already thinking it's nice
it was thinking the exact same thing hey
what's up okay don't know what he was
doing looked like he was taking a nap
she's probably like picking his nose or
he was doing what like switching pilots
or something they're switching loadout
that's a horrible place to say hey I've
seen you switch loadouts and then leg
but sports stream in that's true oh oh
oh bleh I could have Oh executed not
just make that noise yeah I do for the
streamer who's shooting me was you
coming after me see in this room
good question Rob
like some of this some of these
buildings are from what's called Angel
City another map Oh burned at the last
second huh yeah unfortunate it is not a
very generous window oh I see this guy
see you oh I thought you got off the
shot he would have been dead yeah or at
least you guys are crazy
Oh scorch oh yeah scorch is really good
for bounty hunt just killing grunts
farming farming farming that's my life
farm life eh yeah
I'm Sonia life - farm life - you are a
farmer i love farming man that's my jam
that's why that's why i'm actually
mildly interested in the new Assassins
Creed when I have generally no interest
in Assassin's Creed because there's
actually loot in that game man what
weapon was I using that was the EPG what
do you want
Thomas scorches doesn't have much I
taught him though yeah so you're saying
he's a short Titan oh I don't know it's
like he's like hello he went away
oh this cyborg man Rob is playing deny
is a lot better at this denied I am give
me another one do it blinded denied love
it cuz everyone's using now the anti
pain weapon the archer I like that uh
Benjamin he's using the EP Jesus yeah
where are you going Jean here this is
the best part about scores it's tough
it's tough [ __ ] sorry I was gonna nail
this right the window
it's really hard I don't even know if
you can do it sometimes it's sucking
where you going
you got major hull damage
all right arrow oh yeah I feel you a
little bit it definitely didn't come out
at the best time I forgot exactly yeah
in between it was in between battlefield
and cod yeah that was okay yeah that's
why it was like so weird that it
especially cuz you know ei you know
battlefield and titanfall to you like
why wouldn't you space them out yeah
that's weird
the I think the idea being that like
they had their their grounds covered as
far as like you know the era of video
game right like an old basically World
War 2 even with World War 1 it's as far
as civilian and then you know futuristic
like two types of shooters oh but yeah I
mean not the best oh I'm not doing too
big that can
what was that bug man bug man is a dead
man
hole yeah I agree
Bob February would have been a nice
little any time okay worn like when it's
kind of like more dead that's like a
good time because and I'm not trying to
discredit any of the good games all
games that came out and like February
timeframe but it always seems to be a
good time and then because there's not
too much else out but everyone likes
that holiday that q4 because uh you know
holiday spend gifts presents cetera for
the children for the kids get em Rob I
want him we're all shy get naked cow
nope nope nope dumb should kill that
Center oh whoa oh hello
I like this map Oh Mitch be saying you
can fail because EA is a mega
corporation and they do what they want
this is true they do do what they want
and I mean technically they're kind of
like different games you know so o think
you're safe
perfect camera angle they're so awkward
- everyone's using something today oh
[ __ ]
and for good reason that was a Titan
sensor they can shoot pilots that's
weird
really mm maybe I have to bug I don't
know that's odd why why would you use
the pilot sentry then
whoops nope nope that was all wrong oh
no wait Oh awesome
Thank You stranger I don't know who it
was
god bless you but you did what we just
said we were curious about our I was
cured confirmed some firm you know he
saved me an animation what's funny is I
was so confused for a second I was like
did I accidentally execute someone could
I looked away that was really weird that
was where it should be a guy in this
room where do you go to your left
or there was a guy who uh
a man his name's Eric I don't care
Mitch be saying oh wow that was cool I
agree I was like wait yes neck snap like
why the hell don't you alive and like oh
it's friend totally saved us yeah thanks
Benjamin you were right
confirmed I just didn't know to what
extent it would like save or like what
oh the time frame would be like yeah him
to get saved right because it was
clearly about that but was able to get
out of the policy if I can do my my
Titan prime execution Oh God - it hurts
it's so badass well it wasn't bad ass
cuz I didn't see it
oh damn tough crowd so this is the
problem with scorches you really like
you can't use your core ability on this
all right I think you guys know
where's anything like like I can't do
it's all ground get on just go can you
do some three weapons switching action -
oh wait you can't right now yeah I'll
try yeah we'll play about one maybe two
more maps and then cool so James the
extra slot basically gives you another
handgun pistol or another anti-titan
weapon or you load it up and do two of
them if you wanted to like two pistols
review and if you're really crazy you
want to - an Titans I know like what
thanks mezu for the kind words he's
saying you're a good quality streamer oh
that's really nice good job you uh you
hold down the fort though I'm just I'm
like the color guy or you know yeah
exactly
I'm not very good at reading chat
consistently definitely no it's harder
to that's why we have two people right
right right
we it's it's so you can kind of focus on
playing and still talking but I can send
over the the messages and yeah thank you
guys for watching and tuning in we
appreciate it your streaming later
I am streaming later I'm doing some hot
diablo 3 necromancer I guess been
already made his
cuz he just tweeted yo let's go I was
like 16 minutes ago but yeah I'll pretty
much fire up my stream like no a little
bit after this one maybe closer to 1
yeah pretty closer to 1 for me I just
give it a little break get another drink
thanks mezu Glen we were not able to do
free agent says we haven't seen it I
wasn't in the war games playlist alright
it can't be it would have said yeah in
the playlist it says or specifies
wargaming 20 of course 11 work gaming
Jesus war games
oh it says what what you'd play and what
Mo's you play and it's not there I like
this gun James Cornwall saying oh that's
awesome to have you know the ability to
choose between sink or yeah having the
ability to choose between the tank
inside I read that yeah Titan
yeah Israel Jesus yeah I agree cuz you
know if you're playing something like
this as well Oh where'd you go playing a
playlist like this you're you know
you're switching to pilot first pallet
or Titan brawl often and I don't know
like I'm always tampering with my
loadouts but if I'm guaranteed a Titan
weapon and a pistol then I'm like I'm
set yeah bring it on
who's co-hosting with me Ashley's James
I don't know there might not be a ghost
it might be a riding solo thing we'll
see Jessie who's free some of the folks
out in our video editing pit and whatnot
are busy
oh yeah this is a hard point Jesus I
love while running it's so fun I wish I
could do in real life since they're
saying you can't equip to anti-titan MC
well let you I don't know oh we can test
that theory in a second that's what
everyone else in chat was saying so
that's what I relayed as a message if
that's false we'll find out and
apologies in advance if that is wrong I
mean I would never do it so I'm I'm not
fazed by it
it's amped amp it I'm amped still good
I'm surprised it doesn't kill you like
oh hello there the giblets
if I hadn't I got a kernel like son sit
down and I seems so cheap bro yeah yeah
it feels cheap real cheap he's nothing
sure I can change out my weapon no I
like it you're slaying with the EP Jesus
EPG I wanna use a cold war that's
another one that's like has the same
effect it's like a badass the Cold War
yeah there's a sick-ass name huh we got
your back of your stream cellar
thankfully James I appreciate it I
haven't decided if I want to store your
adventure mode pilot locking what that's
a problem there I wanna see this replay
we both know Idaho are you try this see
I'm sure that would make sense though if
you couldn't do too I guess Enoch oh
yeah AJ so it goes back and swallows it
okay thank you I was wrong I will take I
was wrong see the rest of chat that said
that dang it guys come on
no sergeant we're supposed to be a
family I'm sorry
titans be droppin mockolate ro wants you
to camp the S out of them
camp he wants me to camp oh I mean when
when you can still waiting for that
world war ii german accent and that was
someone else requesting that was 19th no
look at digital try to check that out
after he wants us to open up a private
match just to see the options
oh sure that could be the last thing we
do I guess yeah that's a easy one I can
show us show us that quick weapon
swapping yeah I contemplated oh I got my
time like swap weapons quick do it
starting a Oh
oh [ __ ] oh no oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] okay after
all of that what I like it do you ever
do that that that Walt like that corner
wall grab crap Oh wall hang yeah I used
to in the last game it's super fun with
a shot me I held back this is not going
well Eric you've been rodeoed grease
yeah with the shotgun like go into a
room and know some guys like we're right
behind you and just spider-man I'm
spider-man what's that from it's like
it's like notorious or a movie okay
Oh both of you guys oh you shot like the
writer at the box I think and it was
like a smidge higher revenge is on my
mind
hello oh damn oh yes right this is our
house my house another one
Oh watch it dome
we're spit oh another guy oh who is this
who are you where are you where are you
can't the [ __ ] out of him Rob where do
you he got him Danny I can't believe I
survived that this is hot
where can I find the Diablo stream shame
it'll be here on YouTube gaming calm
slash there YouTube gaming that
youtube.com slash GameSpot as well as
twitch that see GameSpot come on Rob
leave he's got the same gun Oh relieving
gutentag each nation hello that was a
pretty good little sesh in that room
thanks
oh that's all I wanted to do I gotta get
used to this weapon switch feels
unnatural to hold down yeah pretty good
oh I should go in here uh uh they did
what they got the betta oh whoa hello
stream highlight yeah I'm sure Rob will
clip that later of this that little
session you had in the room holding oh
sure yeah you got it so I just use the
stream version oh no I have that Rick
when have all these squealing oh oh that
guy knows what's up uh like Rob this is
how you drop the canister oh yeah yeah
there's two of them I was prepping
what's up ISA Roger 66 welcome to the
stream Sal come thanks
Oh nope wrong one
Oh another Butthead Oh breathe I don't
know I was doing those dumb old the
jobless beta no it's actually out today
I did play some of the beta mezu I
didn't play to the point where the necro
weapons and stuff was out yet but I
definitely played beta though with the
new set armors and yeah it's pretty much
as far as I got
give me my school up oh oh oh no no no
no no hang primum Oh or I mean probably
executed nuclear dejection I'm glad oh
come on you can take them oh that's
that's such a cool ass execution like
I'm trying the gut for me trying to get
out and he slammed it shut
I know okay goodbye from the German
crust [ __ ] betta well you want that one
I guess after this we'll show off some
of that private stuff real quick and
then we'll wrap it up you want to look
you want to call now after you show off
some of the private stuff I guess okay I
think it's it's a good time I agree it
to solid matches makes make sense to me
mm-hmm yeah plus honor if you want to
eat before yeah we'd like to get a
something little snack little snacky
snack or a beverage maybe I know also
make sure to that I can buy this update
you notice how all right you got
actually crap yeah all right so see I
don't even know where to begin
invite friends
private masturbator Oh betta good I do I
like potatoes yes I do
those are good that was disco can go
whoa
you're part of the bah it's only now
that you can I switched it and I'd like
to say what a traitor
I'll do the IGN man I need those merits
okay so they're your settings I heard
you can do you can even do health so I
could I could have anywhere from like 25
percent to five hundred percent health
for pilots boost I can turn them off
multiplier so you can just drop Titans
left and right if you want respawn delay
hello Don Juan welcome for Brazil oh
that could be cool just everyone just
has their like core ability or abilities
like all the time all the time at all
these oh look at this okay so look at
here they are so traffic is the live
fire that they announced I mean we
thought it was supported this update but
it's probably gonna roll out maybe in a
week we just shot this should be oh
you're playing that 100 [ __ ] so watch
this what am i watching we can take a
look at the new map okay I mean just for
a few seconds here it is right here
traffic traffic
beep-beep this is currently the private
match beta I guess that we're kind of
messing around with just showing some of
the options I guess now we're gonna
check out a new map traffic so this is
not is this this isn't one from the
previous game right I don't think I
don't believe so this is specific to
this mode live fire so like you know
this is your quick paced last pilot
standing so to speak for you
two rounds really quickly kind of I
don't know about this one I mean already
I'm looking I'm thinking kind of like a
lack of wall-running
ability or dick allottee yeah like I
can't really do much can't go above that
Oh sick good job way to win that round I
don't know how much I'll show all right
cool this that's me and Rob thank you
guys for tuning in thank you for doing a
pretty good job Rob I better than did a
pretty hot job actually yeah better than
last time
I played like garbage last stream we did
so there you go
Redemption it's a redemption story
everyone loves a redemption story um but
yeah that was the new update you guys
can check it out it's live on
PlayStation Xbox I'm guessing probably
PC you know ii can't confirm that last
one yeah if it's yeah but if it's not it
will be in in you know probably by like
5 p.m. mm-hmm and stay tuned for a
diablo 3 necromancer new class streaming
with me maybe someone else will see
that's gonna come shortly probably bout
1 o'clock so see you then thanks can rob
any last words for the No thank you for
joining me
stellar job reading chat engagement
alright thanks guys ream see you guys in
a half an hour if you guys stick around
if not we got multiple streams
throughout the rest of the week so stay
tuned to that 11 o'clock as usual and
some other ones but thanks guys peace
out whose
you